this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
wednesday the 17th of august the joint
is brought to you by draftkings the
official sports betting partner ufc ufc
278 has an action-packed card this
saturday night it's moose month against
edwards to rematch and it's going
[__] down jack this saturday new
customers can bet five dollars to get
203 bets instantly win or lose if that's
not enough action for you holy [__] you
can get up to a ten dollar risk-free
same-day parlay
combine multiple bets like which fighter
will come out on top or how long the
fight will last or will he knock out a
disqualification or a knockout or a
[__] decision listen i don't have any
fight i'm looking at paul acosta i'm
looking at the luke rock called paul
acosta fight i'm looking at the usman
edwards fight and i'm looking at another
fight but nothing's decided till i see
the [__] weigh-ins on friday but
before you get the [__] waynes
download the draftkings app
right now today use promo code joey
you're going to bet 5 hours and then the
ufc 278 fight
and get
bets instantly win or lose that's code
joey j-o-e-y
this saturday at draftking sports book
the official sports betting partner of
the [__] ufc here's the part
the lawyers make me say
minimum age restrictions apply
see the show notes for details now
download the draftking sportsbook app
it's time to make some [__]
money football is upon us also and do
not forget
we're also brought to you by oh my god
[__] go dot factor75.com
tremendous food the summer's winding
down these gonna be the last two busy
weeks than ever that's why i save time
with factor factor is ready to eat meal
delivery with factor a quick lunch or
dinner is just two minutes away
these heat and eat meals are a lifesaver
factor off is over 30 meals per week and
you can change your order up to every
week choose 4 to 18 meals per week
pause or reschedule your deliveries any
time stop spending pression hours in the
store and then in the kitchen sweating
like a [__] maggot let factor deliver
ready-made meals right to your door each
factor meals arise prepared by their
team of chefs and they're ready to eat
and eat in two minutes they offer vegan
veggie keto
press juices smoothies which are [__]
tremendous the energy bites are great
and so much more so do me a favor head
on over to go.factor75.com
joey130 again
[Music]
slash go.facto75.com
130 i'm going to get you 130 off
your first six boxes that's joey code
130 at gold.factor75.com
joey130 to save 130 off your first order
listen so you got food
you got some money to make bets with now
you need to [__] get that dick harder
than [__] arithmetic listen
confidence can take you far it took me
far
but not in the bedroom that's where blue
chew comes in
blue chews an online service fire that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis at a fraction of the
cost i love
[__] blue chew they send you a little
pouch you could put one in your wallet
when you're ready a sling dick voila
it's right in your wallet and the
process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com
you consult one of their medical
providers and once approved you'll re
you'll receive your prescription within
days that's when you call the freaks
jack bluetooth tablets are made in the
usa and shipped in a discrete package
you can benefit from extra confidence
when it's time to perform i'm not saying
you got a d blue chew can help you
either way why show up with a hard dick
when you could show up with a with
superman's dick you understand me try
blue chew for free
when using promo code joey just pay five
dollars for shipping
bluetooth.com
joey for your first month free thank
bluechu for sponsoring the joint let's
get this party started i've been talking
too much
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here welcome to the joint
august the seven [__] teeth
it's a beautiful goddamn day to be alive
i want to talk to you guys listen i'm
getting [__] older you know uh as you
guys could tell the problem is i don't
have no young people i i don't have no
old people watching me old people think
like i'm a [__] joke we probably got
a couple of 50 year olds on patreon and
stuff like that but
the
the viewership or the people who listen
to the show are usually between like 20
and 35 that's my big [__] audience
that's why
people always want to jump on me and ask
me how i attracted such a young audience
like that's the beauty of this whole
journey that i don't have old people
coming to see me it's not like i do a
show and people come dressed up in suits
with hats and their wives are all dolled
up those savages go to like [__] see
jim gaffigan or something like that
those people don't want to see a [__]
savage like me
but i feel at times like even at my age
uh
what i've always wanted to be was to
offer a voice like a
like an adult voice that isn't your
parent it's not your uncle it's not some
[__] boss at work that's trying to
groom you to be a butterscotch maker
whatever the [__] they're trying to
groom you to be
but what we have here is just a guy that
wants to spread some of his [__]
knowledge and a lot of people discourage
me uh discount me because uh the
felonies and stuff like that to me
that's been my strength the all the
fuck-ups i had when i look over that
book i go wow
i'm not a funny guy i'm i'm a [__]
survivor i figured out how to [__]
survive you know
and when you see other survivors they
[__]
you you look at them and go wow
that dude's a [__] survivor a ton of
things have happened in his life and he
still wakes up with a [__] smile on
his face every day ready to tackle the
day
i spoke to some guy a couple weeks ago
he sent me an email that he had been
down that he doesn't leave his house
he's 54 [__] years old he hasn't left
the house
he's had a lot of death in his life you
know and i'm like everybody's had of
their own personal
vietnam everybody everybody you know and
like the man says every hooker got a
hard luck story i'm a hooker i [__]
appease to you guys to sell tickets i'm
a hooker i'm a [__] hooker and i know
that but
when you see people who are survivors
they [__] inspire the [__] out of you
regardless of what's coming out of their
[__] mouth you know regardless
they're doing something that might help
you someday you're not looking at it
like that now but one day you'll some of
that knowledge you go holy [__] this is
what this guy said this is what joey
said this is what joe rogan said tom
segura we've been through it
so and a lot of people when you've been
through something and i sit you down and
go hey man i've been through this let me
tell you how to get out of it you look
at me and go i got a better way
and then you fail you know that's what
we're here for and i'm not gonna say to
you hey you [__] up
no it's just uh we have a better way
sometimes hey listen i don't know how to
change a flat tire
i don't know how to paint the [__]
house i don't know a lot of things but i
know one thing i know about life i told
you [__] la was getting bad
where are we now
i know the streets and i know what
motivates and what gets people fired the
[__] up and when i look at stu final
like the first time i had stu on the
podcast
i got a lot of [__] from people like you
know he's just noisy he's just loud
that's what you see
that's the first thing you see and you
get can't get past it
what i see is a guy that had he was a
millionaire and a bum 10 times over
so obviously he knows something okay
you know at night stu sends me his picks
for the [__] week this guy is money i
get picks from a lot of people like
people hey
look at this game or you know
stu is [__] money those twenty
thousand dollar bets he has
a no [__] joke i gave one to league
how much you win he goes i only bet
fifteen dollars i delete the guy told
you about twenty thousand all minimum
[__] bet on this [__]
the guy is that good but it's not only
that that i'm uh i'm excited about him
it's like what he's doing now you know
he's he he decided to do a [__]
cleanse at 61. i mean just the fact the
guy's smoking blood says 61 has to tell
you how much out of his [__] mind he
is but he's good-hearted he's a good
family man that's a lot of people don't
see when you see guys like stu myself
you're like oh these guys are [__]
out [__] around all day no
that's the image we give you
when people get to meet me like jesus
christ you know i went to this party
saturday night and uh he's a young kid
he came over and he spoke to me i saw
the lady who threw the party yesterday
and we were talking and she goes you
know
my nephew was really shocked by you
that he goes you were very quiet you're
watching the game you were playing with
your daughter
he thought that it was going to be a
smoke attack he was in shock that you
weren't hiring he [__] up i was hot
that's the only way i would have gone to
the [__] party is stoned to the gills
but i put visine on and my eyes are
already used to it you know i did smoke
some [__] tremendous yesterday
and i had to go to get medication at cvs
i took two [__] rips of this [__]
do you know how to pull over before cvs
guys you guys know me a long [__]
time i had a pillow my eyes guys
look like somebody had poked me like i
thought of a ufc fight i kept poking me
in the [__] eye
both of them were bloodshot i kept
hearing a hum in my head
i'm like i gotta pull the [__] over i
pulled though for like seven minutes i
drank my water
and then i went to the [__] parking
lot i walked into cbs thank god there
wasn't a line i walked out of there with
nobody even saw me but i [__] was
like holy [__] i'm [__] stoned like
i'm getting stoned again like remember
high school stone where you got stoned
and you immediately had to eat something
and that type of [__] but again because
i smoke pot people discredit me people
go he doesn't really know what i'm
talking about well guess what with no
[__] college education and all that
[__] i made it all the way to here so
obviously we knew something
and for me it was my heart and my balls
that overcame a lot of things trust me
my heart and balls got me into a lot of
problems also but at the end it did a
lot better for me than not having
[__] balls you know
but without further ado i don't want to
talk no more [__]
i you know stu came on today we did a
zoom which i know you [__]
don't like but again who gives a [__]
what you like
look at what he's got to say
look at what he's got to learn from and
maybe you can apply one of his things to
your [__] life we have no fear we
don't give a [__]
like he said listen we don't give a [__]
if you shut the lights out cancel me
they tried remember a couple of years
ago well joe rogan laughed i
the other day i had to do an interview
with a newspaper
a reporter called me out of the blue and
he goes i'd like to get your take on
something and we were talking about
stand up you know stand up in a world
club culture i think it's some guy in
texas houston
and he goes there's something we have to
discuss he goes
i read into this whole thing what the
[__] was that
and i go guys to this day i can't
realize what that was
that somebody saw a video from 2012
and tried to attack me and rogan but the
funny thing
was like they were throwing rogan under
the bus
with spotify happened there was the
spotify people the jealousy in the air
and they tried to rogan was laughing at
my joke
if you think about that now who the [__]
got pissed at that i know who got pissed
at that and i know who lit the fire to
try to [__] get us down but
guys it ain't gonna happen for you
[__] that want it to happen
suck my dick it's never gonna happen
we're here and i'm calling the [__]
shots of when i leave or when i come
back or whatever i don't play that [__]
at all with you [__] suckers and
that's my thing i don't give a [__] when
i go on stage anymore i'm gonna say
things that are gonna offend people i'm
doing it on purpose
i'm doing it on purpose all these other
jack off comics try to be cute we're
doing it no no i'm not gonna try to be
cute i'm telling you i'm [__] doing
it because i don't give a [__] anymore
it's free reign out there you want to be
woke that's your [__] business take
your woke ass down the [__] corner or
take your [__] ass down the corner but
in my [__] world you ain't
canceling nobody no more so go cancel mr
big he was back on the equalizer last
week so what did you [__] accomplish
people
you accomplished nothing you know you
don't know what really goes on you you
let somebody from 20 years ago come at
you not even knowing that situation
not even knowing her credibility or his
credibility you just believe in them you
know what i'm saying go [__] yourself
anyway enjoy stupid [__] i'm not
coming back afterward word i'm gonna
it's gonna close up and we'll go right
for the sponsors i'm going on vacation
next week we might have a podcast be on
monday and we might not if not we'll be
back on the 29th i think it's the 29th
monday 29th but don't forget
get your [__] draftkings download the
draftkings fantasy app because they're
doing i'm learning about fantasy this
year anyway now let's do finer enjoy
have a great weekend
[Music]
welcome to the joint tarzan
what's up my brother look how good you
[__] look how many pounds have you
lost
um well i got up to 220
and then but i started the 52-week
transformation at 210 now i'm 192 and a
half seven weeks you look great you have
a glow to you
it's never too [__] late to be a
savage brother yeah
is that the [__] truth holy [__]
you know man i told you when i look at
your pictures you have the best
instagram one of the best it just never
ends
not the instagram the twitter i follow
you i think i got you on instagram but
twitter you are [__] hilarious on
that
the food the kids
the yelling yesterday you were yelling
off the top of your lungs i'm like this
[__] guy
is never going to die he's been yelling
like that
for 40 [__] years
wild it's wild listen i mean with the uh
my that's my son's best friend uh
harrison that cooks the food and it's so
easy instead of ordering out or instead
of you know deciding what i'm gonna eat
for the day it's right in front of me
and i can pick and choose from let's say
the chicken meatballs
or the ground turkey stuffed and peppers
or the salmon or the shrimp or veggies
so it gives me a lot of choices and then
you know i'm i'm like i'm so motivated
right now it's crazy joey i'm up at 4 00
a.m
waiting for the [__] crack of dawn i
go downstairs have a cup of coffee i
have my banana and my shoes are on and
i'm just waiting to walk out the [__]
door and it's like a slow jog into a
sprint into a fast walk so i either do a
6.1 mile uh per day or 10.8 a day and uh
now i'm in a group now i'm in the group
i've done i've done over like 213 miles
and i did a 10.8 this morning like it
was butter and now it's much easier
because when we had that heat wave i'm
waking up at four in the morning it's
[__] 90 degrees so the minute i go
outside i'm sweating my [__] dick off
and i put the glide on so my ball sack
doesn't get rubby or my thighs don't get
rubby and uh i'm ready to roll and it's
great because it sets my day the entire
day like the the 10.8 miles takes me
about two hours and 45 minutes and then
the uh
one point the six takes me you know like
about an hour 30 but you know it just
cleanses me so anything that's on my
mind any negative energy anything that's
really bothering me in my gut whether
it's my family you know my kids my wife
my father
business whatever it is you know i get
it out in a positive way instead of
stuffing it or i used to use the carbs
or the sugar or the marijuana and then
that would get me in a fog where i would
have to constantly eat the smoke or do
the carbs or do the sugar to keep that
level up or the caffeine like i'll be
honest with you the main thing i miss
the most is unlimited coffee like i
drink a starbucks french roast so i only
am allowed
three a day
one at four in the morning
one right after the run and then one
right with my eggs and uh i miss that
i'm telling you i love my caffeine high
i love that coffee i was drinking like
10 to 12 cups a day now i'm down to
three so uh but it's a different
lifestyle you know i'm trying to do a
one-year transformation i want to go
down to between 150 to 155 pounds which
then that'll give me ability to run
marathons at will under four hours like
it's butter and i'm gonna try to do a
triathlon not the full triathlon but
it's like a 13 mile run it's a one mile
swim and then it's like 40 miles on the
bike and that would be my ultimate goal
to do that because that's the one thing
that's on my bucket list that i never
actually did so uh but again i'm just
looking for 12 months of just clean
sober abstinence you know when i said
clean silver absolutely i mean no sugar
uh limited carbs no cakes cookies ice
cream and then no marijuana and then um
it's so much easier to live to be honest
with you because you know look we know i
still got a tremendous amount of
problems still fighting with my wife
every [__] day fighting with my kids
every [__] day never a smooth day
ever just that's not life life is
problems and how you know you really
handle [__] problems so basically um
i'm in a good groove right now and i'm
handling the problem so much easier i'm
not overreacting i'm not you know
verbally abusing people because like
when i my first thing when i do my walk
is when i start the day is uh i pray and
i say please god give me the strength to
be abstinent from my compulsive
overeating my gambling my drug addiction
my sexual behavior my abusive language
my compulsive spending and my
selfishness so i'm like i have eight
[__] addictions and it's probably the
reason i haven't killed myself because i
have a little of everything so i never
really had just that one that i would
[__] be you know freebasing in the
[__] corner you know [__] [__]
and i'd be dead already so i had a
little of all the evils and then when
i'm on the straight narrow i'm a lot of
people say stew do you miss it i'm like
[__] no it's so much harder to [__]
smoke a half ounce about a day roll
seven blunts you know [__] you know
do an fall and still have to act like
i'm a [__] human you know what i'm
saying say hello to everybody do what i
gotta do
so uh it feels good to be healthy
um it's going on seven weeks right now
so i don't have that phenomena of
craving where let's say the first four
weeks i'm jonesing you know like every
day i'm just holding on for dear life
the first two weeks nobody in my family
spoke to me because i'm [__]
everybody i'm like get the [__] away
from me what'd you say to me they're
like dad i didn't say anything you know
and the only person that can give me
pure joy where there's no [__] it's
my dog you know dog is unconditional
love hug it out with the door door could
lick its ass for 10 minutes and i let it
lick my face i'm tongue in the door i
don't give a [__] it's my door so but uh
you know i'm in a good place thank god
and uh we're gonna you know we're gonna
[__] roll from there and i'm coming
normally i normally crash right now
coming into the regular season my busy
season which is september through march
and i normally have to lose weight stop
smoking pot get off the sugar get off
the cobs and it's like it's a rat race
like i can't do it because once the
season starts it's just too stressful
but now at least i'm coming in with like
i'll come in almost 10 weeks under my
belt and i feel positive that
everything's gonna flow so i'm looking
forward to it and then uh i just went
online now i saw that you is this your
first book you ever wrote yes the only
book i i don't really really write it
i helped eric a florentine writer jimmy
florentine's sister from he used to have
a show over at uh
barstool
oh wow that's amazing yes so this is so
you dictated to him and he had you know
i had to [__] outline it i had to cry
you know you got to do all that [__]
when you write a book because
for like three years you rub your
[__] face in dirt you're talking
about your past and it's bringing you
back and you're getting new feelings
sometimes
it's very tough the first [__]
five mo well listen i i've been trying
to write that book how i tried to quit
cocaine
i've been trying to write that book for
10 [__] years and it finally took
right i found somebody who i could work
with
very interesting i would love to do it
again
i would love to write a couple books
about different things in time
you know i'm no [__] uh what's that
guy in cuba that wrote the bo i don't
know whoever
that guy used to drink pina coladas on
the beach not shakespeare hemingway i'm
no [__] hemingway but you know it's
interesting to write stu
and everybody has
an ability in them but if you keep
buying books to teach you how to write
you're never going to be a right the
easiest thing i realize after 10 years
just [__] throw away the books
and put paper put pen on that paper
right well let the notebook boo you
until whatever and then you start
getting better and better you know and
next thing you know you know how to
outline i called authors i spoke to
different people
it was rough it beat me the [__] up to
be honest with you it really made me a
different person because
you're constantly looking at your
[__] life every day you know right no
matter nothing really like you start
comparing [__] and you're like you know
what i got i couldn't wait when the book
was finished
and the funny thing was that
i had all the early stuff as a pot
smoker makes you laugh
because now you see the effects of
marijuana which i'm not complaining
about but
the book was very simple from
my coming from cuba
to me
about 2000 was when the book got [__]
difficult
because i don't remember nothing
i don't remember a [__] i remember
the longest yard i remember you know mad
tv
but what was going on it was there was
so much going on plus there was so much
cocaine in my world at that time
i was trying to do comedy and continue a
[__] junky lifestyle there was the
end you could see that the end with
either i was gonna die or i had a quick
comedy there was no i was trying to get
jolts in my neck
like every time i do a [__] line i
get jolt in the middle of night and then
the next day so i knew
something was gonna break but the book
has been a great experience
i can't wait for it to come out i got
one more month with legal because now is
when they ask you like they
you know now we're going into a
different chapter and uh different like
there's three things there's like early
life criminal career and then comedy we
broke it into three things so
by the time i got to like the criminal
career and [__] you know you got to tell
what you did and i wanted the audience
to know
how bad i had it
i wanted them to know how bad it really
was
i push it aside then my buddies call me
and go bro i give you credit i remember
seeing you when you were 17 and you were
raising yourself
you were raising yourself i mean that's
never been done before you were raising
yourself and so all those things it
combined like i'm [__] ready you know
you you go through it but that was the
hardest thing it was 22 000
to [__] recently it was horrible so
we had to take our time and
research [__] but now lawyers are
calling the people because you know they
want to know if people are dead i can't
be telling stories of robbing people in
harlem
you know chasing some drug dealer down
the west side highway you know like
they're like a little scared and i i
understand so we've cleaned up some
stuff now we're about to clean up some
more stuff and then
that's it but still i'm like it's very
i don't know how it makes it what you're
doing inspires me
nice you know i don't want to quit
smoking pot so that's not right i'm not
let me tell you something stu i'm not
smoking the pot i was at all there's no
reason to quit this is like
two bungets here and one [__] freeze
pipe hit at night and i'm done once in a
great blue while if i have insomnia i'll
roll a [__] joint
right but i haven't written a roll the
joint in [__] months like that you
know like i used to so i've cut down and
people at home don't really understand
what you're saying at times how
intense your life is this ain't no
[__] joke
if you look at stress and stuff i think
after i met you in 91 i clocked you at
10 years
because you were such a high energy guy
you can't continue that pace but people
don't know there's a ying and a yang
and guys like you utilize yang and yang
when we have the yang we go all the [__]
out but we're off camera we're laying
down with our feet up petting the
[__] dog
people think guys like you and i are out
at night eating somebody's [__]
snorting coke lighting that [__] on
fire
i mean i'd like to do that if i still
could but i can't i'm you know
so it's very inspiring what you're doing
stew thank you and i see what you're
doing you're getting it ready for
football season so your best you've had
a phenomenal [__] baseball season the
last weeks
you've been totally on [__] fire the
last two weeks of baseball the totals i
mean you know
and it's hard what you do it's very
[__] hard but i see
the 30-year experience when you give out
your picks i understand now ah
i see what this [__] is doing
he's a savage
right so i mean like with the thing i i
miss like i miss
rolling the blunch i miss
hanging
with my kids and smoking because for me
smoking like brings me back to a child
again i'm [__] 61 but i roll a blunt
and i'm smoking i'm telling stories of
people and i roll a second blood i roll
a third one i take a thousand milligrams
of edibles and people looking at me like
are you [__] [__] what's the
matter with you aren't you high i'm like
yeah but i just i just love it i just
love i almost love the act of doing it
and the reason i had to stop it wasn't
like god came down and there was this
catholicism it's like wow i'm going to
be clean my [__] doctor put me
against the wall my sugars were 460. my
a1c for over a year straight was over
13. and he said i don't know how you're
not dead yet or how you haven't gone
blind or how your dick doesn't it still
works or how your feet haven't fallen
off but it's only a matter of time
you're just gonna be walking around one
day in front of your [__] kids and
you're gonna die you're gonna just
[__] die and ain't gonna be bringing
you to the hospital and saving you
you're [__] dead
and for some reason it just hit me that
it was it's a it's a very simple
decision when the power of that hit
because it was either i was gonna live
or i was gonna die and i was killing
myself and damn straight there's nobody
that loves smoking pot more than me
there's nobody that loves eating 15 000
calories more than me and just [__]
acting like a child hanging with the
kids bonding with the kids acting like a
kid meaning no responsibility you feel
invincible there's nothing you can't do
you can snort an eight ball you can
snort a second [__] eight ball and
then you're ready to [__] go you know
what i mean and you're ready to roll and
you and me for some reason god has given
us the ability we you know we got 10
lives each we should have been dead you
know 20 years ago but by the grace of
god god has given us the strength to
come back from failure after failure
catastrophe after catastrophe
self-sabotage and the self-sabotage
after self-sabotage you know we don't
lose our enthusiasm you know you know
they don't make them like you and me no
more because you you could kill us we're
coming [__] back baby we're coming
back from the dead you know you're the
phantom sports uh you're the phantom
comedian i'm the phantom [__]
handicapper just like steve maholick was
the phantom bodybuilder you know after
he did his steroids and he did all his
drugs and he [__] thousands of women
got a [__] car accident almost died
and he told me these stories and then it
gave me the strength so like you're a
power example for me because now that
you know like when i talk to comedians
you're the comedian's comedian like not
only do people [__] love you but the
pros love you because like nobody ever
wants to go on after you that's all i
that's all the [__] rep used to have
like if you were [__] in the room and
they had to come on after you it was a
nightmare for them because you destroyed
the audience you know like when you kill
for 20 30 40 50 60 minutes and then
someone else comes on you got nothing
left you're like even the little teeny
parts when i saw you in atlantic city
and you banged out like 20 minutes i
[__] died because i [__] love you
you could [__] say hello and i'm like
because because i [__] genuinely love
you you know i feel that we have a
kindred bond we have a kindred spirit we
come different stories different
circumstances but from the same place
you know you come from cuba you're a
cuban i'm a [__] jew we both were
treated like second-class citizens we
were treated like you know like skunk
you know like people did not treat us
right and the reason i think we got
balls of [__] stone and a heart that
won't [__] quit and a desire that you
know i i'm gonna do it because i've been
to [__] hell i've been dead already
something you could [__] do to me
baby i've been to [__] hell i've been
[__] wishing i wish to die couldn't
kill myself couldn't [__] die it's
our story so i again i'm an inspiration
to you you're an inspiration to me so it
feels good that we bonded again i cannot
wait to introduce you for your show with
the sony kid i'm just gonna [__] be
screaming yelling i'm gonna be yelling
so i'm gonna lose my [__] voice that
night just getting that crap that
crowd's gonna be so hype when you
[__] walk on we might have to have
tenfold security because they might jump
on the [__] stage you want to hug you
and eat your ass and blow you and finger
[__] your ball sack you know what that's
what's gonna [__] happen it's gonna
be [__] insane we got a dj oh we got
weed coming they're gonna give our
[__] envelopes laughing gas it's it's
uh
i'm excited listen anything on when they
said broadway
if you know anything about anybody who
grew up in this area especially in the
70s broadway was everything in my world
it's broadway and bergeron line avenue
in jersey those are my two that i know
every nook you know every i walked i
used to live on 98th street and i'd walk
to times square and watch movies with my
godfather as a kid no english
no [__] english so you have no idea
when i think of [__] joey diaz on
broadway
even though it's my name i think about
walking down
broadway and seeing a big [__] statue
of george lazenby that one half of [__]
james bond they had for a while he came
in for one movie in between like the
saint and uh sean connery or something
that's what i think of like that's the
pride i get in my heart like you know
what yeah i did this
this happened this happened but this is
broadway you can't take this from
somebody
this is a [__] trump this is like
when people said well i saw
you know
paul mccartney last week for the small
800 [__]
i saw [__] david gilmour do the solo
to comfortably numb on top of the wharf
the nassau coliseum for 15 and 50 cents
suck my dick and call me shorty don't
get better than that for 15 [__]
dollars you know these are things that i
did that uh mean the world to me
so broadway
i've even started writing a little bit
like i just something inspired me a
couple i said i'm gonna put the notebook
down until i get back from vacation [__]
that the other night i was like let me
break this down
i want to give them a good show it's
gonna take time but you know it's gonna
be
is going to be better than the last one
you know and then let's see where the
[__] it takes us right five shows that's
going to be amazing
and then i got philadelphia i'm
releasing
the night before thanksgiving okay and
that's a great [__] casino parks
casino oh i mean i didn't want to do any
casinos but this one is exceptional the
food is great when i go to philadelphia
i mean i'm from jersey i'm from new york
city but when i go to
philadelphia i just feel like i'm one of
them as crazy as this seems when people
talk about philadelphia i take a little
bit of offense in my heart when they
call them animals and sabbath they go
you know what i am an animal and a
[__] savage let me tell you how much
i love philadelphia and mike will tell
you the last time i did parks i usually
go in the back and get my head together
drink some water you know make sure i
don't have armpit [__] odor and then
i go out and shake hands and see
everybody in philadelphia i just put the
mic in and i jumped into the audience
and i was out there with them you know
how many people grabbed my [__] in
philadelphia
there was a guy that came up to me and
go he goes my mom this is uncle joey i
told you he's got balls and why he got
he said to his mom he had balls he
kneeled
and he grabbed my [__] and i don't know
what to do because i know the guy is not
doing a lot of disrespect
he's just grabbing my balls going
they're my these are [__] balls i
wish he could show them to you would you
show them to my mother come on man i'm
[__] 58 you want me to show my boss
to your mother what is wrong with these
philadelphia [__]
on the drive home you let no security ah
there was no [__] i don't need security
in philadelphia i don't need security in
two places philadelphia and [__] in the
bronx i don't know what it is with
puerto ricans they stick on to me i love
them with all my heart i just went to
yankee stadium two puerto ricans
stuck on to me they walked me to my
[__] chair
that's like nobody's gonna mess with you
right and i'm like wow
well they have passion they have the
passion that you really do
nobody's gonna measure you in the book
major [__] passion in the bronx but
major passion in philadelphia too i mean
absolutely i think park's casino was
barcelona's signature sports book i love
him i [__] love i think that's a sp
that says
great food the hotel's across the street
so if you got a chaser you know what i'm
saying she's across the street
let me ask you a question stupid when
the [__]
are you gonna write a book well i did
write a book i have a book written okay
did you know that yeah it's called
yeah it's called uh here
i can
so i released this right after the movie
true for the money and that releases and
then that that was my that was my book
and then this book
starts off this book is similar to like
your story a little bit where it starts
off
um where i'm about to kill myself i'm
about to take pills and end it because
my wife finally found out that i owed
like you know half a million dollars to
friends family mafia and i was jammed up
and i told her nothing about my position
and i was balls broke and i was about to
lose everything and then
she found out not by me being honest and
telling her so that um that's how the
book starts and it starts from all the
way from the beginning
um to uh you know when i made it so in
other words it's a great story and uh
i'm looking again similar to you once
you release your i'm looking to write a
second book now my second book i would
want to continue with the barstool
sports advisors story in addition to
doing stand-up comedy i always wanted to
do one night at westbury so that's 3 500
[__] place out you know big cat and
pft and all the boston people said they
would come you know i would pray to god
my greatest son it would be you [__]
introduced me
i just got an offer for the paramount
if you want to do westbury
we could do westbury
let's let's do westbury i would love to
have you
[__] on fire whoever likes that [__]
on fire gets five thousand then
listen that's it and any gay guy that
lights his [__] on fire and puts a
sparkler in it i'm giving you five grand
we're going for big parties i'll i'll
send you i'll send you this book because
no just bring it to new york okay
it's
it's like you take your [__] on the
[__] toilet you smoke a drink an hour
and a half roller coaster ride you know
i wrote it like a third grade because
i'm a third grader i only got 390 on my
sats and english and i can't spell [__]
and that's pretty much how i wrote the
[__] book pretty much like that i
dictated it to one of my best buddies
who did a nice job with it and uh you
know and yeah listen i i sell like at
least 15 a day people love it i
personalize it you know they want me to
do the 15 15 30. so i say hey listen
kill your girl
let her let you eat her ass lick her
[__] and [__] her you know i'm saying
and i always saw it you know my father
taught me two things if you can't eat it
don't [__] it and no one and no one ever
got pregnant blowing your load in their
mouth and their [__] so a lot of
these guys out there now like i don't
want to get pregnant i don't want to get
a girl pregnant hey listen so blow a
load of the mouth and blow a load or
[__] you know and just eat the
[__] [__] that's the [__] bottom
line baby let's [__] go let's [__]
go
i mean that's really the bottom line now
do you know about this thing that bar
still has called rough and rowdy do you
know what that is you explain it to me
okay so so like five and five seven
years ago maybe eight years ago ten
years ago dave portnoy used to go to
this psycho place in west virginia and
it was called rough and rowdy you would
have 20 fights
three one minute rounds and you would
get local people in the area with no
experience at all to just [__] murder
each other three one minute rounds 20
fights ps like what are we in so he
bought it in 2016 and i think bar stool
has put on 18
uh
fights and most of them are in west
virginia this one upcoming friday is in
huntington west virginia and it's the
fundamentals it's the craziest thing
ever you get 20 fights three one minute
rounds they have midgets fight they have
women fight they have these psycho
[__] girls walking around ring girls
waving their asses and thongs playing
with their [__] [__] and their
tits and then at the end you vote on the
hottest ring girl and then there's
always a couple of major fights so this
guy that i got very friendly with um
that works for them called coach doug's
and how he got a job at barcelos there
was a cartoon of a video there was a
cartoon of him he looks like a coach and
they hired him off of that it's the
craziest thing this guy's like maybe
about six to five hundred pounds and
he's the main event and he made me his
manager so we're fighting some guy in
canada
we don't know anything about this guy in
canada all you know is he played [__]
rug to be for 12 years and looks like a
killer now my guy who's fighting doug's
nicest [__] guy in the world very
determined high integrity not a killer
not a killer but he's trained his
[__] dick off every day goes into the
gym throws up every day you know [__]
it's crazy so he's the main event on
friday night and uh they they sell like
50 000 pay-per-view events matter of
fact they had jose canseco remember
the best the baseball player they had
jose canseco fight somebody at bar store
this guy uh billy hot tates and jose
conseco got paid like a million dollars
and took a dive the first 10 seconds
into the round billy went at him and he
fell and the fight was over so he was
crazy it was unlocked but he made a
million dollars he sold like 150 000
pay-per-view events like 50 bucks or
something psycho like that so everybody
made money so then now dave puts up in
the contract where you can't throw the
fight you know you can't fix it it's got
to be a real [__] fight but so on
friday he's the main event and then the
second main event is this girl alex
bennett that works at boston too she's a
sweetheart her and a mother have a
podcast together and she also has a
couple of podcasts with a couple of
other people this great woman called
jordan woodruff they do a great thing
together and
um she's amazing she's drop dead
gorgeous the sweetest woman in the world
her husband's father owns the oklahoma
city thunder so no one even knew that
she's working at borrow story think
she's like you know a grinder meanwhile
she's a [__] billionaire but so she's
fighting she never fought the [__]
life
she never fought but she's been [__]
training like an animal so those are the
two main events and then you have like
three midgets fighting three men digits
and then you have girl midgets and then
you just have crazy people because it's
only three wonderful no they're crazy
three one minute rounds you go all out i
was supposed to fight
2018 i was the headliner on my birthday
january 31st in miami when the super
bowl was in miami i'm training i'm going
to be the main event i'm easily going to
make between a quarter of a million to a
half a million dollars because the deal
then was i got a piece of the
pay-per-view a big chunk and i moved the
needle similarly you move the [__]
needle it doesn't matter what you do
you're gonna be taking a [__] in the
corner taking a piss in front of
everybody the needle moves joey diaz
ruins
you know what i'm saying you move the
[__] needle baby you know what i'm
saying clips stand up and attention
[__] little nipples get [__] hot
you move the [__] needle men women
children then people come out of the
grave oh i moved the needle so i'm
[__] i'm training like a [__]
animal training throw a punch i tear my
[__] bicep
from here it comes up to here
[__] done done so wait
hey dave what's the compensation
uh dick dick no no wait you don't pay
for the operation nothing it's due it's
the [__] fight game it's brut so i
made nothing nothing so i get the
operation
not only this the operation doesn't go
good i'm in a [__] brace for nine
months because my hand was like locked
in like this i had to wear a brace to
open my hand up for five hours a day for
nine months hell i wanted to kill myself
and you know i said dave no compensation
it's like hey
tough break
tough break and that's the truth that's
the fight game it's a tough [__]
break just like you know these ufc guys
they fight they grind you get [__]
hurt your career is over before you made
the big money hey that's the [__] way
it is you know dave says hey stu i gave
you an opportunity to make a quarter of
a million to half a million dollars if
you didn't get hurt that's the positive
the negative if you're 57 and a fat
[__] slob and you got [__] hurt
big deal hey it's over you know just
like [__] david daniel white says hey
i give you the platform you think i'm
underpaying you where the [__] can you
have a shot to have your [__] face in
front of the [__] world [__]
grind it out you [__] you stay
healthy you make it so um so now i'm a
manager you know i'm a manager so i
don't know like i'm gonna like our theme
song to walk out for the fight is hulk
hogan say after we're done with this i'm
going to party city i'm getting a hulk
hogan costume and i'm going to come out
his whole called and screaming and
yelling and then hyping the place up and
then uh it's so much fun you got to come
to the next one obviously you're going
away i think you're going to the north
carolina or something on vacation right
okay so the next one i think is in
november or something but it is so wild
it is so it you don't it's crazy it's
like
wwe or wwf wrestling but real because if
you don't jersey and nothing like that
long island the rule the law state laws
right they haven't paid they they won't
allow it yet but eventually they will
they won't allow it correct but
eventually they they allowed one in um
uh providence rhode island which was the
closest to uh boston and most of them
are in west virginia huntington west
virginia all over the all these towns in
west virginia so huntington is right
where the uh university marshall is
so uh marshall university the college
where
where that plane went down and killed
like 200 people and the whole football
team was wiped out yeah so in other
words and then matthew mcconaughey made
the movie about it so
so uh yeah so that's what's going on now
so i'm so psyched
and i like so what i do every day right
now is i grind out with my voice i do
what's called these stew finer shout
outs whether it's your birthday
anniversary bachelor party you want to
[__] somebody to death or i read
the fantasy football lineup i pick the
order and then i read it and then they
give me some bullet points and i torch
the [__] people and so i'm doing
between seven to twenty a day diving off
my [__] diving board it's 125 if i
sit on the board and read it 175 i dive
in the [__] pool but this is but this
is like a three this is like a i'm
writing like ten thousand a week
freedom three to four minute pitch so i
have no voice at the end of the day i'm
spraying my voice i'm trying to figure
you know i'm over a hot [__] a hot
like vapor thing doing this fixed vapor
rug i'm running it my greatest fear is
to wake up with no [__] voice because
i'm done like tits on a boat i'm useless
my dick my dick right now since i lost
like a little bit because i measure it
because i'm stupid [__] and i'm a psycho
is six and an eighth
when i was super fat it was five and
seven eight so i gained like a quarter
inch quarter inch works baby you know
whatever every little quarter inch works
when you only got that you know and then
if if i ca if they need more than six
and a [__] eighth inch i got two
[__] fists [__] these fists
going
fist [__] you that's what i [__] do
and if the fists don't work i carry a
12-inch vibrator with my face on again
my tongue goes
it hits that [__] porous or
i swallow pink champagne put it in my
mouth go down eat the [__] and these
little bubbles go
and they hit the clitoris that stands in
attention and they go snooze
i love you i never felt like this now i
know what i've been missing i'm like
tell me some you don't know you [__]
and that's really how we roll so
brother i am [__] excited when i talk
to you something
we're both around the same age
we grew up in the city when the city was
the city
we grew up in this world with when this
world was easy to explain to people now
it's a hard world to explain to people
and it's kind of weird for guys like you
and i
and i'm i'm asking you this just as a
concern not because
i don't give a [__] and i could see
obviously you don't give a [__]
do you ever have any thoughts of
somebody might raise their hand and go
what the [__] is stu and joey diaz doing
on the podcast
they're all the gentlemen they're out
there yelling about it you got to eat
somebody's [__] and you got to finger
bang them or midgets i don't give a [__]
you know you and i come from a time that
i understand that it's
listening a lot of blm a lot of all this
stuff i get it
but i can't stop saying the word [__]
because i've been saying that for 30
years 40 50 years and now you want to
change the rules
so there's all these rules that are
coming up you know by if you who's over
there looking at you your son is over
there i know that's good i don't give a
[__] i want them to say hello but it's
so weird how
do you have any fear of this that
somebody's gonna call uh barstool and go
what's this guy yelling about because i
love you i love it
but this in today's world but i also
feel that there's three people that you
can't cancel and that's me you and pete
rose because we're gonna tell you to
suck our dick
okay well i refuse to let somebody judge
me that's not a [__] judge and i'm
talking about the judge that
put his hand on the chick's mouth
he's the 20th circuit whatever the [__]
he is supreme court justice in my world
if he tells me to get off the internet i
will listen it's i [__] up
but nobody nobody got the right to
[__] say
stu finally we got to get him off i put
a minute on i got offended how do you
feel about this dude
well i mean obviously dave portnoy um
loves me and unconditionally has my back
you know barring me going off the rails
where i would hurt the company uh i can
get away with murderer i'm almost
untouchable you know what i mean i'm
uncansatable
right but
but that's not the case on twitter or on
instagram or on facebook or on snapchat
let me give you a perfect example it's
so amazing you said this perfect example
saturday saturday my buddy buys a
breathtaking car brand new refurbishes
like a 1957
old school breathtaking car blow you
know buys the car for 20 puts 30 into
the car okay he puts the car online and
i look at the car and my exact comment
right to him right under it is i want to
[__] you and eat your ass in that car
immediately facebook suspends me
i cannot post for three days and now for
the next 30 days well now it's the next
27 days they put my feed at the bottom
of everybody's post
so in other words
i have to adjust because i do not want
like they've pulled down my twitter
twice already with a hundred and some
thousand followers i'm shadow banned
everywhere like i should have a million
to two million followers on instagram
and twitter but similar to what you're
saying because of my sexual content
because of the rage i come at people
which absolutely can be misdued as being
a psycho as threatening somebody as
being in someone's face they don't get
my intent they don't know my intent nor
do they care they just blatantly do it
so i i have to be extremely extremely
careful to not be taking off twitter or
instagram or facebook or snapchat i just
gave you a perfect example now i'm i'm
restricted i'm shadow bin where i do not
go into people's feeds like
my content a lot of times unless you
actually come to my page and click
your my stuff does not pop up in
people's feeds
so they they what's called shadow band
me they always had they always did like
my my key my key saying is i will kill
your bookmaker that doesn't work no more
can't say it because the word kill
they're taking literally where i don't i
don't mean it literally i mean it's
figuratively you know i will win money
for the client and and hurt the
bookmaker and that's a euphemism to kill
can't use the word kill no more even my
15 15 30 where i think on the prior
podcast i told you i created the perfect
hour of sex 15 minutes eating ass 15
minutes licking [__] 30 minutes [__]
you can't hold your load bring a vibrato
i can't get away with that no more
there's there's you can't say it people
cannot say it online cannot say it
because again
i don't even know it but they shadow
banned everything what happened dave
portnoy where he got accused by these
business insiders these low-light piece
of [__] scumbags accused him of stuff
that he pat they were patently false it
was not true he's suing them but
but now his feed his fee does not go
into your feet he's shadow bad now so in
other words when you say to me do i give
a [__] um will it change me no but i
have to be careful with what i say i
literally have to be careful because my
message won't get out as it is my
message doesn't get out i'm only in like
11 of people's speeds so it does suck
but when you but when you say that to me
you know i understand what you're coming
from because the content is you're
saying it to your [__] buddy you know
just like joe said hey i want to call
somebody that because it's his [__]
birthday you know i i love the guy like
i can call my friend up my best friends
and say hey your wife's over here
[__] blowing me i'll i'm gonna be
over your house about 10 minutes let her
just clean up
they know what that means that's love
that's [__] you know you could say
that to your [__] buddies you could
say that to your best friends but you
cannot say it to the world because
they're going to take it literally and
they're going to say that we're a bad
influence on people where it's the
direct opposite we're showing people
that you have to have a sense of humor
don't take yourself so seriously it
isn't a literal uh representation it's
figurative and we're comedians but again
you know what the the walls are coming
in us very squeezed we're sweet we're
getting squeezed we're literally getting
squeezed there's no issue about that
really i'm not getting squeezed i i
understand
we're also businessmen so facebook
shut me down like three times this year
so far one for 30.
i'm thinking of taking it down because
facebook don't do dick for me anyway
it's just a bunch of people from school
or whatever you communicate with they
don't reach out to what you know it
doesn't uh
i don't want those people involved with
what i'm doing in a way but instagram oh
my god
facebook owns instagram right so [__]
instagram
right that's scares me but instagram is
my bread and butt you know i like
instagram right they take down all my
weed stuff
right but there's like a chick sucking a
dick there no you know what it is
two chicks that suck dick all day on
twitter very subjective
very subjective who they enforce and who
they let slide when i smoke a blunt
and i show it on camera for the next
month my calls my my feed and my views
are 80 down
because of the marijuana like you just
said because in certain states it's
still not legal and they don't want that
to the general consumer you know what i
mean it's almost like they really should
have
two twitters and two instagrams they
should have an instagram for 21 and
under which you and me we would know how
to play that and twitter and instagram
21 and over where we're just anything
goes everything goes let's [__] go
just like an r-rated movie or an nc-17
movie you know what you're getting you
know what you're getting involved with
let's [__] go but that's not what we
do so unfortunately especially the way
we do our content they judge us as a
three to 11 year old could be looking at
it being influenced does not understand
the message does not have the skill set
to understand where we're coming from
you know what i'm saying and then you
know that hurts that really does hurt so
uh you know but face i love facebook is
like like you said those are my friends
they don't they're not on instagram and
twitter everybody use instagram
those you know those are the people that
are our age that are not internet savvy
that have no idea and they just want to
click on you know so a lot of things
that i do like my motivational message
my motivational speeches my eating clean
my running videos by telling people you
know the way out is the way through
disagree set free don't ever let [__]
tell somebody tell you they can't do it
fail you have to fail you don't lose
your enthusiasm that's a positive
message but they destroy when i
[__] people and i do words and i
get a little you know i get very edgy
like you do i go way over the top i
crawl there is no line i'm [__] in
your [__] wife's bush i'm eating her
ass you know so in other words you know
so it's it's it's uh i have to walk a
very very thin line a very thin line i
don't like it it it inhibits me certain
times but i don't have a choice you know
what i mean i don't have a choice you
know i'm not as big as you to be
opposite you know yes you are brother
you're a [__] well i'm i'm these kids
down the block from me at el nido
every time i see these [__]
they asked me about you
so i'd surprised him the other day and
said he's going to be doing the shows
with me all of them
all of them he'll be there you can talk
to him whatever the [__] he's dancing
he's taking off his whatever these guys
are so excited to meet you
i thought they were excited about
meeting bert they were like [__] bert we
want to go it's still fine i'm like okay
you can come see [__] still fighting
but no we're uh
now i'm starting to get
what i'm doing finally
like i'm starting to you know i was
reading some jiu-jitsu thing about
training when you're older and then like
you know
you're in there to set an example some
days you know you like i do the warm-ups
i don't care if my knee hurts you know i
get there on time and all and that's all
great and dandy and that's what i'm
trying to do
with the podcast now i've always been
like you
don't believe the [__] hype you can
do whatever the [__] you want even with
felonies if you put your mind to it
they'll tell you you can't do it in
prison when you get released
they ask you if you want to go on
disability because the felony will hold
you back from being anything in your
life you sign that paperwork you're dead
you're living on 800 a month for the
rest of your life yeah i know
you know until you end back up in jail
because that's what you've committed to
being a felon when i got out of there
even now if i order a
if i got to go apply for a job i was i
don't even know what you're talking
about do you have a felony in the last
three years no i don't i don't know
nothing and then let them come back to
me and go well we did a background check
jose you got a phone that's great that's
for a guy who has a felony and wears
that as superman i don't give a [__] i
got it as a reminder to let me know i'm
never going back there but i'm not
laying i'm no laid down sally
i don't give a [__] what they tell you
you got to keep pushing forward and
that's our message which is positive but
every once in a while you get some
[__] jerk offs and you got time to
suck your dick boom you canceled twitter
on the other hand i got no complaint
about twitter
mike has been my dear friend for years
he knows what i post on twitter
if they going deep in my twitter they're
gonna find some [__] and [__] but i
don't give a [__]
i'm not going to make up an excuse i i
can't make an opportunity you know i
love osama what's his name uh obama's
wife
i [__] love her you know i haven't
seen her lately she was getting big but
for a while there i like i really like
her i think she's attractive with the
mouth the whole thing and one day i
wrote on there i'll suck the blank ain't
got a [__] and [__] oh my god i got
like hatred but i'm just saying how good
of a looking of a woman she is i didn't
mean nothing but if somebody sees that
now from 2016 which i'm letting you know
is on there i don't even give a [__] go
do what you got to do
right it was like you gave her you gave
her literally
the ultimate compliment women loved it
she was so gorgeous [__] that you would
want to literally be with her
i'll drink the champagne
i'll do everything but they took that
literal as as an affront to you know the
first lady and they thought that was
demeaning and degrading where that's the
direct opposite you mean the first lady
the first lady like [__] jack they all
like
the other first ladies were just 100
years old they weren't you know nancy
reagan just saying no you don't want no
[__] you know that poor [__] she didn't
even know the [__] was when she was in
the [__] white house
i heard she was sucking uh frank
sinatra's dick i heard that i don't know
how yeah it is 100 true when ronald
reagan used to call in because i read
like five books on reagan and on sinatra
and on nancy reagan she she loved his
dick she loved it i mean i wasn't there
let's get something out of the way
everybody likes sinatra's dick i guess
that's true everybody every [__]
woman right
that's true that is true do i know i
know you're doing great with [__]
baseball right now when does your
football package start the 10th of
august
uh yes you know what it is because
preseason now is very shaky because
five years ago preseason they played for
real and they wanted to win but now they
don't because they added a game to the
nfl so preseason is very very shaky so i
still get out preseason and i'm still
gonna long games this weekend you got
games thursday friday sunday monday i'm
gonna go for it but it's just not people
don't like to bet it as much years ago i
was able to sell it and it was great but
yeah september 10th uh starts the first
football game and we'll be able ready to
roll the nfl is going to be [__]
amazing amazing this year
on september 10th and college also
college starts august 27th oh [__]
that's coming quick this is next
saturday yeah it's like 10 games 12
games and then you got your labor day
and then you're full full blown baby
where can these savages get you do you
have anything for this you saturday's
ufc it's a big card i'm pushing on
draftkings um i normally give out the
ufc for free i don't really sell it you
know what i mean like if you buy the
package and i have a selection on and i
give it for free but as a rule of thumb
for me
ufc
underdogs [__] underdogs the
favorites don't cover they rarely cover
like i mean obviously when khabib's
fight mcgregor you're betting khabib
because he fights bears and he's a
psycho and he's never lost it he's never
gonna lose you know what i mean like for
certain people but but most of the time
if you bet the underdog the entire card
you bet all the dogs in the ufc you're
gonna make money you're just gonna make
money you make money with the underdog
because those [__] favorites pay ten
dollars and they got great props too a
lot of these places different books have
great props like i won
a [__] handful of dough by mistake i
bet 20 like a pool
that uh moreno would knock out that dude
last week two weeks ago it was like 20
bucks to win 150. wow how can i not
[__] go with that so there's always
little side things right
right i love betty underdogs because
it's exciting you know what i'm saying
you bet the favor he's supposed to
[__] win you know like right but uh
yeah so i mean the underdogs would be
the way to go in ufc on an overall
picture overall picture yes you made my
tuesday i'm happy i [__] listen i
love you we'll do another one before the
show on the 17th get ready for football
season and then when i get back i want
to go over the bar stool yes she's ready
for you not the [__] not the week
before labor day because everybody's
thinking about oh gods after that
absolutely get it forward i got some
other things
and now we're gonna make those shows in
new york city a [__] trip and then
we're all leading to your movie theater
in westbury all right let's do some
other comics and we'll do a nice little
[__]
okay that's how we do it brother and you
get your bucket list i'm doing it for
you guys
they just offered me the paramount i
said no not yet
but if you want to do we could do it
like next june i could do the paramount
with you i'm ready no not the paramount
don't worry that's where you want to go
so that's what you're doing
done westbury
i love you i love you black don't forget
the yarmulke brother i love you stu has
the only yamaha it's got a thousand
dollar bill hidden in it you know what
i'm saying
and a condom you got it i love you
brother stay black my best to your
family your wife
thank you for being a great friend you
got it
all right i want to thank stu finder but
most importantly i want to thank you
[__] savages for always supporting
the show but this week we got factor
you're like joey what's the fact the
fact is ready to eat meal delivery
with factor quick lunch or dinner is
just two minutes away they eat and eat
meals are a lifesaver you understand me
my wife loves them factor off is 30
meals per week and you can change your
order every week
choose from four to 18 meals per week
and you can pause or reschedule
deliveries
any time stop spending hours in the
kitchen and at the store waiting online
people breathing on you left factor
delivered ready-made meals right to your
door they offer vegan veggie keto
cold pressed juices smoothies energy
bites and a lot lot more so do me a
favor head on over to go.factor75.com
joey130 again
use codejoey130 to get 130 off across
six boxes that's code joey 130 i go
factor go dot factor 75 dot com slash
joey 130. listen i'm not gonna tell you
again saturday night it's all going down
it's ufc 278 usman versus edwards and
the action starts at draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
part in the ufc this [__] saturday
got a tremendous card you could bet five
dollars let me fight it and get 203 bets
win or lose they're doing you a big
[__] favor draftkings is the best
when it comes to football baseball
basketball but the ufc tremendous they
also offer a ten dollar risk-free same
day parlor you combine [__] multiple
bets if they're gonna last three rounds
or the five i love draft picks i love
draftkings
i gotta love this card the reason i love
draftkings is they're safe secure and
reliable and you can withdraw your cash
whenever you want but they also make
sports gambling fun so download the
draftkings sportsbook app right now
today use promo code joey i tell you
what else they got that's great the
[__] draftkings daily fantasy daily
fantasy they're offering like a million
dollars in prizes and you're here
jumping up and down i'm giving you a
reason to jump up and down so download
the draftking sportsbook app and
download the fantasy app and here's the
part the lawyers make me say minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply see
my show notes for details draftkings now
go win some [__] gidas the joint is
also brought to you by blue listen
i'm not saying you have erectile
dysfunction what i'm saying is you can
use more confidence when you come into a
situation blue chew is an online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets all at a fraction of
the cost i love them i love
blue chew they're easy you can take them
on an empty stomach in the morning
whenever the [__] you ready to make love
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com
consult with one of the medical
providers once you're approved you
receive your prescription within days in
the mail nobody even knows you're
getting them the best part if it's all
done online no visits to the doctors no
awkward conversations no waiting online
at the pharmacy listen bluetooth tablets
are made in the usf a and shipped in a
discreet package i'm not saying you got
a d but if you could
benefit from a little extra confidence
what the [__] guys blue chew can help
you try bluetooth for free when using
promo code joey just pay five hours for
shipping that's bluechew.com
code joey for the first month for free
visit bluetooth.com for important safety
information and thank bluechu for
sponsoring the joint i want to thank
bluechu draftkings
liquid iv anybody who is in our world
this but most importantly i want to
thank you savages have a great day have
a great weekend and i'll see you
[__] monday morning
tip top magoo maybe
you